l'invité de télématin joël robuchon
profession artiste ou chef ou cuisiniers
en tout cas étoile montante de la
cuisine française
rebonjour joël robuchon alors est ce que
ça vous monte à la tête de devenir une
vedette et pourquoi devenez-vous une
vedette d'un voyage porte encore
m'attaque j'arrive à rentrer dedans puis
toute façon ce n'est pas ce qui me
préoccupe vous savez je fais un métier
qui est passionnant c'est un métier on
se remet en cause à chaque service on
nous juge en fonction du dernier repas
fait donc nous comme nous sommes pas
parfaits on peut toujours faire mieux
alors voyez il ya des choses beaucoup
plus importantes vous êtes un angoissé
c'est un métier on est toujours inquiet
vous savez quand on fait la cuisine
quand on le fait avec amour quand on
fait avec passion il peut y avoir
beaucoup de choses le produit il peut y
avoir des jours sans et donc on n'est
jamais sûr vous savez que avant un
service vous passeriez en cuisine il ya
18 cuisinier pour faire 45 couverts mais
vous entendez pas un mot pas un murmure
tout le monde est anxieux tout le monde
est tendu tout le monde a peur de mal
faire ne pas réussir
et alors pour que devenez-vous une
vedette ça je ne sais pas si je deviens
une vedette
est ce que ce sont les guides qui
fabrique les vedettes le disons que les
guides la presse gastronomique et toute
la presse en fin de compte c est
beaucoup pour un restaurateur et c'est
indispensable maintenant et peut-être
permets moi qui ai commencé son temps
comme je disais tout à l'heure à 15 ans
je n'aurais pas eu les guides les
journalistes il est certain que
peut-être que je n'aurais pas pu le
réussir à maintenir une maison tout aux
mâles de l'acheter le match
et à ce niveau là et les guides sont
vraiment indispensables à notre école et
quand on devient une vedette qu'est ce
que ça change dans la vie de tous les
jours on vous regarde un peu avec avec
mystère écoutez moi je vois pas de je me
rends pas compte je ne vois pas il n'y a
pas de changement pour moi
il ya qu un but qui m'intéresse est de
toujours faire mieux toujours essayé de
donner le plus de satisfaction possible
à la clientèle mais vous êtes trop de
cela parce que vous êtes vraiment un nom
coûteux c'est vrai je suis un commerçant
aussi donc il faut se faire connaître
pour la maison il faut que je travaille
mais
le but principal je crois nous sommes
des manuels des gestuelles des
cuisiniers donc il faut le rester avant
tout mettez nous l'eau à la bouche
qu'est ce que vous préparez pour midi
écoutez là on a quelques produits là
aujourd'hui
vous savez que dans ce métier on
travaille toujours le produit de saison
bon ben là il ya les projets des
aubergines c'est les meilleurs me ment
donc là on va pas parler des tourtières
d'agneau aux courgettes aubergines et
automates
bon là ça gigote 1 devant vous dites moi
comment je dis ça gigote à gauche oui
alors la langouste moi j'y connais les
deux donc l'onho mars et celui qui a de
passer la langouste n'a pas de pain
saint paul affirme haussier mais
pourquoi j'ai mis des homards on vient
d'y recevoir et vous savez que c'est la
saison il faut manger les crustacés
parce qu ils sont 50% à 80% moins cher
que l'époque où on les mange le plus
c'est-à-dire noël ou premier de l'an et
c'est là où ils sont le meilleur c'est à
dire que c'est toujours un petit peu le
produit de rêve qu'on n'ose pas aborder
parce qu'il est cher mais que là on peut
trouver vraiment à des prix raisonnables
parce que peut-être pour 50 francs 60
francs et surtout si vous êtes en bord
de mer vous arrivez à trouver un produit
de 400 grammes et je crois que ça fait
quand même une belle portion est donc il
faut en profiter c'est là où ils sont de
meilleurs ils sont beaucoup le moins
cher merci beaucoup je leur bouchon nous
le tout ça devant pour dit il il a une
petite recette de crustacés que le doute
roland lui à lui arracher dans son livre
c'est formidable parce que dans une même
dans une même coquille midi l'armée
plusieurs c'est qui est pas bête du tout
à mon avis voyez il met plein de petits
coquillages dans le grand prix mais à
wimille mouline 8 une palourde une prune
coque et un vernis haché mais je sais à
ce temps là ça fait bizarre
non ça nous fait rêver comme bah oui
parce que vous êtes levés très tôt il
est midi poule
[Musique]